early on
in this weekend richard dawkins stepped
into the public sphere once again
with a challenge and here it is in this
tweet
kafka's metamorphosis is called a major
work of literature
why if it's sci-fi it's bad sci-fi
if like animal farm it's an allegory an
allegory of what
scholarly answers range from pretentious
freudian to far-fetched feminist
i don't get it where are the emperor's
clothes
and this tweet generated a lot of
commentary and responses many of which i
think are completely on point
i'll you know i won't candy code it and
i'll give you a little preview dawkins
really made himself look like a fool
in saying these things and so we're
going to begin with
three very interesting tweets here's a
good one
one morning when richard dawkins woke
from troubled dreams he found himself
afflicted in his thread
by a horrible ratio so yes
it indeed was horrible from the
perspective of
very negative but there's a lot of
really great
on point and funny responses
in there here's another really good one
it would be befitting
if the original popularizer of the term
meme
became the subject of one riffing on his
incisive literary criticism
on display here and you know there's a
lot of irony levels packed into this
isn't it uh you know the his incisive
literary criticism it's anything but
but you know dawkins himself
although somebody who did coin this this
idea
he didn't actually come up with it the
idea had been around for a long time but
he came up with a catchy phrase for it
that
then took legs of its own uh
meme he just doesn't get twitter or the
internet and he's made a fool of himself
at many other points and then here's
another great one again
invoking kafka right to be fair to
dawkins here
imagine having to live with people's
unrealistic
expectations of you day in day out for
years
until one day you wake up and realize
you don't even recognize yourself
anymore
if only someone found a way to describe
experience in a book which is indeed
what
the metamorphosis is doing and is part
of the reason
why it is such a great work of
literature
if we go on there's a few other very
interesting
points being made here this is a very
nice one
that's an astonishingly honest take most
people would
be embarrassed to express that view
publicly so i commend you for that i
guess
and then guy who is not only read animal
farm reading his second work of
literature
not getting a lot of animal farm vibes
from this
and then here's another one which i
think is completely on point oh crap
he didn't read the assignment and has to
[ __ ] his way through a book report
it's okay buddy we've all been there
and then finally hello richard
metamorphosis is about how scary it
would be to turn into a huge bug
hope this helps we go on and and
some people took up this uh funny little
trope or one liner about the emperor's
new clothes
so one person pointed out the emperor's
new clothes only works when the emperor
is actually
naked metamorphosis is a story about
alienation and class powerlessness
aside from that it is haunting unnerving
and sometimes funny
and this is a really good one because
it's pointing out well why
why do people read it what is richard
dawkins not getting right these are some
of the
positive attributes another one i see
what happened here there's actually not
an
emperor in that one richard i can
understand why it would be so
disappointing to wait for the emperor to
show up for the whole book
with no payoff common mistake sorry this
happened to you
so you know you're saying essentially
richard dawkins mixed his metaphors so
badly that he turned it all
into intellectual mud and then here's
one
playing off of dawkins own formulation
here
the emperor's clothes which emperor
where is this so-called empire are we to
trust a city would not contain one
honest person brave enough to speak the
truth
is an emperor this blatantly stupid not
unfit to rule if like the big bang it's
an allegory an
allegory of what and then finally you
know a much more
straight to the point one he uh he
doesn't have any clothes because he's a
giant bug you obviously didn't read the
story
uh ditchard uh and then here's here's uh
two more that are leading up to what is
the story really about
i don't know man kids in high school get
it and then
how does this dude not understand the
easiest allegory for alienation
anyone's encountered i mean i know that
when i teach the metamorphosis that's
one of the key things
that we talk about and my students who
are not philosophy students by the way
or even literature students
they have no problem getting it here's a
whole host of ones
it's simply about alienation isolation
and inferiority in working class
communities it captures what happens
when those
around you stop regarding you as human
it's not a tough one to get if you
have even a hint of poetry in your soul
most of kafka is about alienation and
isolation and loneliness
here's another one the metamorphosis is
among other things a metaphor for
relationships based not on genuine
compassion friendship or love
but usefulness gregor is a man gave his
life to serving his family when he was
no longer useful they gradually
abandoned him
another one my own reading of kafka's
metamorphosis was one of existential
empowerment
regardless of personal predicament the
story wasn't about gregor but of his
family they began as parasites of gregor
by the end embrace living their life
despite no change in their condition now
that's actually an interesting
interpretation one that i haven't myself
come across it doesn't seem to fit into
dawkins worries about you know freudian
or feminist it's
it's a bit more straightforward than
that and it's actually
off the cuff you know very good
interpretation
finally the first time i read it i
didn't understand when i read it in
college after having watched my
grandparents health decline in an in-law
suite as we saw them less and less
it spoke to me like when the family
starts storing furniture in his room
wow so these are like you know people
having
very quick easy reactions to the story
that dawkins seems to have missed
entirely it's hard to
understand how dawkins could be so dense
about that let's go on here richard
dawkins acknowledges complete
cluelessness about the literary and
philosophical movements
known broadly as existentialism and geez
no the metamorphosis is not sci-fi
here's another one what do you call
fiction that advances no ideology and he
has no interest in
obeying the laws of material reality
literature dick you call
it literature right and then here's an
even more
biting critique i too divide all
literature into the three categories of
sci-fi allegory and bad
finally the novella should have had a
last page where it explained everything
and broke it down in very simple black
and white terms
to me this is what good literature is so
really you know
poking it to him now we get into the
ones that talk about dawkins himself
so this is quite a good one it's about a
once respected man
dawkins who turns into a pest i'm sure
you could understand it if you try
and i really want him to do a series
where he analyzes classic works of art
mona lisa
more like mona lisa she won't even smile
properly what is this picasso nonsense
kids can draw better than that
don't get me started on warhol i mean if
you did apply dawkins
methodology or crankology whatever it
happens to be on his part
that's what you would get and this is
the best one this reboot of reading
rainbow sucks balls
yeah you wouldn't want dawkins in charge
of anything that required that
now we get to some even more biting ones
dawkins the selfish gene is called a
major work why
if it's philosophy of biology it's bad
philosophy of biology
if like the origin of species it's
science we must ask
a science of what idiot's responses
range from leave my dad alone until you
hate western civilization
and then here's another one along the
same line dawkins the selfish gene is
called the major work of biology
why if it's genetics it's bad genetics
if like the origin of species it's an
explanation an explanation of what
scholarly answers range from racist
eugenics to far-fetched new atheist i
don't get it
and so you know dawkins own
this is a clear case of being hoisted by
your own petard right
then here's another good one focusing on
dawkins himself
richard dawkins is called a great
thinker why
if it's as a scientist he's a has been
if like bertrand russell as it's as a
public intellectual
of what answers range from smug new
atheists to the intellectual dark web
i don't get it where are the emperors
close focusing
once again on that now here we get a
whole bunch of them
right where we're saying well we can
apply the same thing to other things
so first and as for the castle kafka's
you know
novel if you're looking for a guide to
medieval fortifications or a handbook on
bureaucracy it's bloody useless
right richard dawkins on waiting for
godot another existentialist work good
dough is called a major work of
literature
why i mean he's in the title but he
doesn't turn up
and they start the second half of the
song but i mean it's not a musical and
what's with the moon right here's
another good one
in terms of modernist literature people
are always going on about proust i don't
get it wow a guy eats a cookie
that brings it all back what do you do
for you frenchie right so
you know totally missing the point about
proust's entire project mary shelley's
frankenstein is called a major work of
literature
why if it's if it's sci-fi it's bad
sci-fi a manual to reanimate organic
matter both galvanism and vitalism are
discredited
scholarly answers range from pretentious
freudian to far-fetched feminists and
that's actually true for
for frankenstein not necessarily
pretentious and far-fetched
but yeah that is the case and then here
we get a kid's book the monster at the
end of the
this book is called a major work of
literature why
if it's sci-fi it's bad sci-fi if like
little bunny fufu
it's an allegory an allegory of what you
know hopping through the forest picking
up all the field mice bopping them on
the head
if you don't know that little song
that's another
one and then finally here's neon genesis
evangel
evangelion is called a major work of
anime why if it's sci-fi it's bad sci-fi
if like animal farm it's an allegory and
allegory of what
scholarly answers range from pretentious
rey to far-fetched asuka i don't get it
how is masato not best girl
we have another page of these sorts of
things as well if it's a rock opera
where are the songs if it's a railroad
track what train would run on it if it's
a cheesecake what part is the crust
preschool answers run from what to huh i
don't get it and because i don't get it
there must be nothing to get great one
here about
a different type of art rothko is called
a great artist
why if his paintings are landscapes
they're bad landscapes if like the mona
lisa their portraits a portrait of who
and i feel the same way about garcia
marquez's
100 years of solitude there are a lot of
characters in the novel i mean if it's
bad history it's bad history
where's the solitude and then finally
what about natalie portman turning into
a black swan what is even that
about the movie black swan
then we get a whole bunch that are
spoofing
richard dawkins himself waking up like
uh
you know the character in the
metamorphosis richard d awoke one
morning to find himself accused of not
getting a famous novel he pleaded
fruitlessly with experts to refute him
but his judgment was left in suspense
who was the true judge to settle it or
were all emperors naked what a trial and
how will dee's story end so that one's
about
the trial and then we get as an empty
tweet box awoke one evening from uneasy
dreams that found himself
transformed in its bed into an enormous
pile of pointless grump about 106 year
old book
the transformation of richard dawkins
into the pub bore was not overnight
as richard dawkins awoke one morning
from uneasy dreams he found himself
transformed in his bed into a gigantic
loser
one morning richard dawkins awoke from
uneasy dreams to find he'd been
transformed
into vapid irrelevance and then finally
the last two here
as gregor samhsa awoke one morning from
uneasy dreams he found himself
transformed in his bed into a gigantic
stem bro
one morning after many years of terrible
tweets richard dawkins awoke to find
himself transformed
into an internet troll there is one more
of these
this is the best one i think imagine a
man
who once had a good reputation as a
biologist
but who awoke one morning from uneasy
dreams to find himself transformed
into intolerant philistine and
pseudo-scientific huckster
finally the very last tweet that i
wanted to put
into this video which captures the
absurdity of this
dang this is just like an animal farm
when you find out that
holden caught field is guys are so safe
blending together all sorts of stuff so
that
is uh what we've got here dawkins has
clearly given us plenty to
think about and perhaps even meme about
and that's where we will end this
you